estamos viendo en la pantalla un
ejercicio sobre demostraciones de líneas
y ángulos en khan academy entonces
veamos qué es lo que se nos pide dice
las líneas a b y d son paralelas realiza
una traslación que demuestre que los
ángulos correspondientes siempre son
iguales y elige la opción que explique
la demostración muy bien entonces veamos
que tenemos aquí en el dibujo
ok entonces aquí tenemos a los ángulos
correspondientes xy
esos son ángulos correspondientes
tenemos aquí este ángulo inferior
derecho que sí y este ángulo inferior
derecho x
entonces estos ángulos son
correspondientes y la línea f es una
línea transversal a las paralelas a b y
d
esa es una transversal a estas dos
paralelas entonces queremos demostrar
que los ángulos xy que son iguales
queremos demostrar que tienen la misma
medida y hay varias maneras de hacer
esto geométricamente ya lo hemos hecho
en varios vídeos secan academy pero aquí
se nos da la opción de hacer una
traslación
entonces yo primo el botón trasladar y
cuando muevo esto observa lo que pasa
aquí se trasladan los puntos entonces yo
voy a tomar al punto de lo nuevo y se
traslada esa intersección se traslada
todo si yo me hago el punto d al punto b
que pasa una traslación siempre preserva
los ángulos los ángulos no cambian de
medida en una traslación entonces cuando
yo traslado al punto d
yo voy a hacer una transacción cuando yo
traslado el punto d se empieza a
trasladar todo observas pero una
traslación preserva ángulos entonces yo
muevo a este punto de ello lo traslado y
lo que hace es que está trasladando los
ángulos también el ángulo cede que tiene
por medida x cuando yo muevo el punto d
sigue midiendo lo mismo ese ángulo se
preserva preserva su medida entonces
observa lo que sucede yo traslado al
punto d en el punto b
y qué es lo que pasa estoy trasladando
los ángulos encaja perfectamente eso
quiere decir que esos ángulos miden lo
mismo ajá miden exactamente lo mismo
estoy trasladando el punto d en el punto
b estoy trasladando al ángulo x en el
ángulo y y encaja perfectamente así que
veamos qué opciones que opciones tenemos
que describen lo que lo que hicimos
veamos qué opciones tenemos
la primera opción dice dado que la
imagen de una línea sometida a una
traslación es paralela a la línea
original la traslación que mapea el
punto d en el punto b también mapea el
ángulo cdf en el ángulo ave de las
traslaciones preservan las medidas de
ángulos entonces x es igual a ye esta
opción suena razonable pero le damos las
siguientes la traslación que mapea el
punto f en el punto d produce una nueva
línea que es una bisectriz del segmento
de b
eso no lo hice así que desde aquí ya
empieza a sonar algo sospechoso este
inciso pero bueno sigo leyendo dice la
construcción de la media tris en
presencia de las líneas paralelas sabe y
demuestra que x es igual a i
suena algo sospechoso luego el siguiente
inciso la traslación que pape al punto d
en el punto produce un paralelogramo por
lo tanto x es igual a ye veamos eso eso
es cierto mira observa esto si se
produce un paralelogramo si yo traslado
el punto d en el punto y voy a trasladar
el punto d en el punto i se va a formar
un paralelogramo pero no veo no veo de
qué forma esto nos ayuda a resolver el
problema y demostrar que los ángulos x y
ye son iguales entonces bueno regreso a
esto como estaba y la opción correcta es
la primera opción entonces bueno vamos a
comprobar nuestra respuesta la primera
opción es la correcta y comprueba tu
respuesta bien hagamos hagamos otro
ejercicio muy bien entonces en este
nuevo ejercicio dice las líneas
y bueno pudieron simplemente decir que
tenemos la línea ave pero supongo que al
decir a o b nos indican que él
o está sobre esa línea es decir que los
puntos v son co lineales entonces las
líneas a b y c o d son líneas rectas
cuando estas proposiciones demuestra que
los ángulos opuestos por el vértice
siempre son iguales
-bueno ángulos opuestos son ángulos
ángulos opuestos por alguna intersección
de líneas por ejemplo los ángulos
jose y el ángulo dv son ángulos opuestos
por el vértice y si queremos demostrar
que esos ángulos son iguales debemos
probar que miden lo mismo es decir que
alfa mide lo mismo que beta entonces
veamos cuál de estas opciones es la
correcta
la primera opción dice el segmento oa es
congruente con el segmento o de eso no
lo sabemos eso no se nos dice en la
información que que nos proporcionaron
para resolver este ejercicio así que
esta no es la opción correcta porque no
sabemos si esos segmentos son
congruentes no no sé si esos segmentos
miden lo mismo entonces esta opción
definitivamente
no es la correcta entonces pasamos a la
siguiente opción porque no sabemos si
esos sí si el si el segmento oa es
congruente con el segmento o de entonces
siguiente opción
la segunda opción dice una rotación
alrededor del punto que mapea la línea
veo a en la línea de 12 entonces aquí
estamos rotando alrededor del punto o la
línea veo a en la línea de osse descrita
por un ángulo alfa o un ángulo beta eso
implica que los ángulos sean iguales
esto es una interesante tenemos aquí una
rotación alrededor del punto o que mapea
a la línea veo a en la línea de 12
cuando yo roto alrededor del punto o un
ángulo beta
y mapeo yo a la línea veo a en la línea
de ose cuando yo roto un ángulo alfa
alrededor de y entonces eso suena am eso
es cierto eso es una razonable pero
veamos la última opción que nos dice la
última opción dice una rotación
alrededor del punto o por un ángulo
gamma entonces vamos a rotar en un
ángulo gamma alrededor del punto o mapea
ode en oa yo sé en v eso es cierto eso
es cierto pero bueno veamos que dice
dice los segmentos adyacentes a los
ángulos alfa y beta son congruentes así
que los ángulos deben ser iguales eso no
lo sabemos no sabemos si esos segmentos
adyacentes a los ángulos alfa y beta son
congruentes no nos dan esa información
entonces bueno esta opción no es así que
él dijo la segunda opción la segunda
opción
vamos a rotar alrededor del punto que
mapea veo a en 12 y eso es escrito por
un ángulo alfa un ángulo beta así que
los ángulos deben ser iguales esa es la
opción correcta entonces la elijo
comprobó la respuesta y estamos en lo
correcto y bueno sería todo de
demostraciones de líneas y ángulos por
ahora nos vemos